[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
Georgia
the whole day through
Bonnie Willis
it's signaling that she's gonna file
charges in the Trump election
interference case
in Georgia sometime between July 31st
and August 18th it seems
it seems that way
oh boy this is going to be a fun summer
isn't it oh my God apparently Chris
Christie's gonna get in the race this
may change my view no it's not going to
change mine do you want anything
you would think that oh well Chris
Christie's gonna get in this race and
he's gonna he's gonna really go after
Trump come on man
come on you you think that's the worst
that can happen here
I I would assume
it's my assumption it's probably gonna
be correct at some time in the beginning
uh weeks of August because uh what
finally Willis has done is she has
um signal that she's gonna give charges
because she's asking the judge not to
set any court dates within a three-week
period because her office is going to be
working from home my guess is is that
they see that there's going to be bomb
threats
there's gonna be threats on the lives of
the prosecutors their staffs uh I mean
this is this is how this is how manga is
they're [__] domestic terrorists
this is this is why
they're gonna work from home
they don't they don't want to have
people in that building when there's
people who could pose threats
to the prosecutors that are going to
prospect prosecute Trump and his allies
for election interference in Georgia
now what does this mean about the Jack
Smith case
it it appears that
the D.A Willis in Fulton County Georgia
is not really making her decisions based
on what Jack Smith is doing
it's becoming more and more clear in
that direction also in this same in this
same case the judge rejected Trump's
21-day extension basically told them
[__] off
and Trump is trying to get fonnie Willis
removed as a prosecutor and it's not um
it's not working
so you can take your stupid motions and
stick them up your ass
Grandpa
that's basically what the judge told him
not even giving him uh one day extension
out there are begging even in the
chapter saying indict him already he is
indicted
he's already hit the business that he
ran folks this is the [__] that really
infuriates me to no end
the business that he ran for decades
Trump organizations was found guilty of
17 counts of fraud
felony criminal fraud
Yes No One's Gonna See jail time besides
Alan weisselberg which it appears also
in the Manhattan DA's office that Alvin
Bragg may be bring more charges against
Alan weiselberg
in some of these new uh charges criminal
charges in business fraud
but he's already convicted
there through the Trump organization he
ran it was his [__] company this is
what he was doing
him and his second Man In Charge Alan
weiselberg he's he's charged and
indicted on 34 felony counts of business
fraud in the Manhattan DA's office right
now
Jack Smith is barreling in on his ass on
this document's case
because it's pretty material as far as
evidence goes
yesterday we watched as one of one of
the
[__] players in the documents case
cash Patel was outed by Daniel Goldman
the Democratic congressman
freshman congressman
from New York when he questioned Jim
Jordan Jordan's on whistleblower
non-whistleblower and ask if cash Patel
is paying him he said well yeah of
course he's under oath he has to both of
them did both of them are being paid by
cash Patel that's right the same
[__] that said Donald Trump can
declassify documents with his mind and
then once cash Patel went and testified
before Jack Smith you haven't heard a
goddamn word out of him
I know you're frustrated about him being
indicted but he is he's a criminal
he's indicted criminal and a convicted
criminal business Criminal
soon he will be a political criminal
soon don't worry it's going to happen
everything Trump touches turns the
liquid [__] but this does not change the
fact that he's gonna be the nominee
everyone's like oh yeah Tim Scott he's
gonna run
he's got 22 million dollars in his War
chest to spend
what a waste
what a [__] can you think of a more
waste of money of 22 million dollars
than Tim Scott acting like he's gonna
get into a primary race
what the [__] are you kidding me
and then Chris Christie's gonna announce
Rhonda santis man I've been telling you
for [__] weeks dude Ronnie pudding
fingers if you want a [__] run man
you better do it I'm like tomorrow you
[__] keep waiting till June why
what are you doing just [__] get out
there in front of a microphone and say
it
you
listen I understand that everyone thinks
Rhonda santis is the person who's going
to challenge Donald Trump's nomination
you are a [__] bonehead you are not
paying attention to Rhonda Santos he is
a [__] [__] he can't even figure out
to stop talking about Disney he can't
figure it out he doesn't know it he's a
stupid [__] he's a dumb son of a [__]
and if he had any [__] brains he
would get out in front of Chris Christie
here because Chris Christie isn't going
to just [__]
kick Trump's ass he's gonna bury
DeSantis too
you think Chris Christie's gonna keep
his mouth shut about Ron DeSantis you're
a [__] dummy
Chris Christie was was the governor of
New Jersey I don't know if you remember
this he shut down the bridge killed
people in an ambulance and [__]
because he didn't like it he didn't like
it so Chris Christie you don't think
Chris Christie's gonna go why was a
better Governor than this [__]
you don't think he's gonna do that
come on
Chris Christie getting in the race
doesn't hurt Trump folks
it hurts DeSantis
that's right Chris Christie getting in
the rates does not hurt Trump at all no
one no listen to me no one getting in
this race is Gonna Hurt Trump's chances
to be the nominee who you point them out
to me
and give me some sort of evidence that's
going to prove to me that these brain
dead morons these [__] idiots
aren't gonna vote for Trump in the
primary an affiliation isn't going to
win over in those primaries No One's
Gonna Stand in his way
and why would we let them why do we why
would we want them to stand in his way
you understand the best chance to save
democracy is for the biggest [__]
loser in this country to run on the
Republican ticket
huh you know that right
oh now Rob here says uh uh Liz Cheney
good luck
I'm taught we're talking about a primary
see that's that's the thing that
everyone is missing this election is not
about the general election it's not
about the actual presidential election
it's not what it is it's not even close
don't even think about Democrat versus
Republicans stop thinking that way
that's not what this race is this race
is everyone against Trump and the thing
is the more the more people that get it
the more Republicans that get in this
primary the more these Nazis get in this
primary the better it is for Trump and
the worse it is for someone like Chris
Christie or DeSantis you know that right
listen you you have to go to the
convention and win on the floor with
delegates okay now the Republican uh
national uh party is different than the
Democratic National party and the
conventions are different and how they
select their nominees are a little
different but in general it's the same
you have a convention you go to
Convention with delegates you've gained
those delegates through primary
processes some of them are caucuses some
of them are votes some of them are party
conventions like here in Missouri no one
really knows this it's kind of funny
actually here in Missouri when you go
vote
and if you pull a Republican primary
ticket okay and you pull a Republican
primary ticket and you vote for
Republican you're not actually deciding
who that who the party is going to send
its delegates to
the the State Convention decides that
not now in in the Democratic primary
Missouri it's different Democrats just
are like oh that's who the people want
so that's who's gonna be who's gonna get
delegates not the Republican Party
and that's the thing these aren't these
aren't
these aren't state and federal
sanctioned events these are party
sanctioned primaries
it's Republican versus Republican and we
should make them fight
that's the whole key so Chris Christie
getting in excites the [__] out of me it
doesn't make me go oh my God what what's
gonna happen if Chris Christie gets in
honestly I hope Chris Christie gets in
before Ron DeSantis
I really do I hope Curtis Chrissy gets
in before Ron DeSantis that is that that
actually proves my point that I've been
talking about more the last four months
than anything else
it's great
and all gonna be in the heels of this
summer okay so think about this let's
say in the next few weeks Chris Christie
and Ronda santis get in the race now
we're in the gym okay
we're there's gonna be a a deluge of
news
on this documents case and it's gonna
get worse and worse and worse for Trump
on this documents case and you're not
gonna see anyone no one
but maybe Chris Christie Chris Christie
May attack Trump on this documents thing
he may he might but you're not going to
see anyone else attack him on this
documents thing the reason why is
because you can't take the side of the
corrupt FBI and doj they're weaponizing
government against Republicans don't you
see how he's already set up his win
their entire narrative
is that is that any Justice Done against
a republican in this country is totally
corrupt and it's all a Witch Hunt
what other [__] is under
criminal indictment that is running for
president on the Republican side who
who
tell me show me show me who is
criminated or about to be crimin
indicted on the Republican side that's
running for president United States
besides Donald Trump
their entire National narrative Rhonda
santis is really trying to make this
[__] this this [__] wokism and
he's today even
he said the word faucism what the [__]
are you [__] me okay man try a
little hard there putting fingers listen
the entire National narrative the entire
National Republican party's push is to
defund the FBI to get rid of the doj
to totally get rid of the ATF okay
there's a reason for all of that
the reason is is they're trying to
convince the sheep that everything
against Trump is to keep him from being
present and that's the reason why
they're gonna nominate him
DeSantis doesn't have a shot in [__]
hell neither does Tim Scott or Assa
Hutchinson are
[__] Nikki Haley or Vivek
any of these dumb son of a [__]
especially Rhonda santis they don't have
a shot in hell
and the reason why is because the entire
narrative the entire National narrative
in the Republican party is to elect
Donald Trump
they're trying hard I'm I'm going to
show you a few folks that are trying
really hard to convince trumpers that
Trump is a trump and he's not Maca
enough and Miranda Santos is more Maga
than Trump
it's it's not it's not gonna work
it just isn't this Disney stuff isn't
enough
it's it's not gonna work Ron and man
honestly
and honestly if if you wanna if you want
to run
do it now I mean I would suggest
you get out in front of the microphone
right now at least you'd have at least
at least about let's see we've got uh
you know we got about eight weeks for
Donald Trump
maybe 10 weeks for Donald Trump
is indicted in Georgia him and his
allies God knows how many people are
going to be [__] indicted in this
case holy [__]
there's gonna be a lot of people
indicted in this case there's going to
be a lot of immunity given a lot of
deals that we're given
that's what's taking so long in Georgia
I believe in Fulton County they're
trying to lock up all the testimony
trying to lock up all the deals who's
gonna flip on who
and there's a lot of State legis
legislators and a lot of and a lot of
former legislators that are wrapped up
in this in these uh this election fraud
scheme
this this fake electors
and really honestly if if this
prosecution is as rock solid as it
sounds like Fannie Willis has it it is
only a road map for Michigan and Arizona
to bring some of these cases against
people if it was the same kind of scheme
in those States
to somehow fraudulently uh submit fake
collectors
so that Trump could overturn our vote
[__] that [__]
so
we're gonna see we're gonna see where it
leads we're gonna see where it leads but
listen I'm telling you I know you want
him to be indicted and I know you want
to see him in an orange jumpsuit and
hand gifts and all that [__] I get it I
get it I get the imagery I get the
feeling I understand that you're like
yeah woohoo yeah [__] that [__] send
him to jail I get it I get it he's not
gonna go to jail yet he's gonna be
indicted again and more more
jurisdictions rather it's Fulton County
Georgia or it's Washington DC under Jack
Smith it's gonna happen but it's not
gonna stop him from being the nominee
that's what you need to stop thinking is
that him getting indicted is only going
to propel him to the nomination folks
I don't know if you've been paying
attention but these moglodytes
are [__] delusional
they're dumber than dog [__]
some of these [__] idiots are
cheering cheering that Rhonda zantes is
like [__] your billion dollar investment
Disney and Dizzy's like okay I don't
give a [__] we'll go another state
invest a billion dollars we don't need
your 2 000 woke ass jobs Disney like
okay yeah all right great for the
Florida economy you're doing great work
here governor
and they're cheering it they're like we
don't want these blue voters here in
Georgia what the [__] are you talking
about do you think Disney like when they
build a some sort of complex
they're like are you a democratic voter
are you part of the lgbtq community
are you are you from the woke California
are you moving to Florida so we can
overturn elections because we're trying
to create jobs here to bring blue voters
to Georgia you people are dumb as dog
[__] man
[__] is wrong with you
how how haven't you people figured out
how jobs in the economy works it's like
the whole [__] idea that rich
[__] like Elon Musk are job
creators get me a [__] break
he's not a job grader he's proven that
he brags about it I got rid of it 90 of
the jobs at Twitter oh great job job
Creator [__] out of here with that
nonsense
you know what you know what
you know what does create jobs uh when
you build a big complex and hire people
to work at that complex that tends to
build some jobs
I mean maybe when you when you build an
entire economy and people move to that
area for those jobs and other businesses
spring up I don't know you know like
provide services and goods for those new
people in that area as it grows that's
why cities are like oh we need growth we
need growth in our city because they
want the um the uh what is it called the
economy too what is it grow
um it's almost like people are the thing
that makes the economy grow it's almost
like that happens for some [__] weird
reason
but moglodytes don't understand these
things they don't get it why do you
think they're going to do it Like Donald
Trump
they're [__] delusional like oh it's
all Witch Hunt
of course of course the FBI and the doj
is weaponized against just him think
about this this is the entire entire
thought process
that Democrats right Democrats who will
be uh who will beat Donald Trump beat
him in 16 with the popular vote beat him
in 2020 by 8 million votes okay
eight million [__] votes is what we
beat That sumbitch by in the popular
mode
and somehow they think we're scared of
Donald Trump in 2024
That We're Not Gonna pile more votes on
top of him
what and that we don't know where Joe
Biden's votes are because we know where
the Biden votes are folks we know where
those votes lie
the 81 million people that vote for him
Democrat Democrats know where they where
they're at
and you think we're scared of trump
so much so that Democrats are gonna
somehow use their influence in power
to take over the FBI in the doj to
weaponize it because we're scared to run
an election against Trump are you
[__] kidding me [__] out of here with
that nonsense no one likes that
[__] I mean a few brain dead
white men in this country but that's it
and maybe maybe a few others you know
Fringe outliers most of it is fragile
white men
the majority of his support
just like him
so yeah we want him to run we should
want him to run what better way to
[__] get fascism American fascism
trumpism to crawl back underneath this
rock sooner rather than later than to
beat him over and over and over again to
a bloody pulp
yeah sure certainly let's do that I
don't give a [__] let's I I hope he runs
in 2028 from a prison cell
don't you
they will probably nominate him can you
imagine think about this think about him
losing in 2024 by I don't know 10 12
million votes that's the margin the
Biden wins by that seems how the how the
how the demographics are shifting
and then in 2028 he's in a prison cell
somewhere for God knows what [__]
indictments
that he's been that he'll finally go to
trial for maybe he'll be on house arrest
maybe he'll actually be in a prison cell
but he could possibly run again
I mean maybe though 14th his ass
when it's shown that he tried to commit
a coup on our government
maybe I don't know
but do we want to do that do you want to
not have him lose
the popular vote four times in a row can
you imagine that think about that for a
second think about this think about this
that that's four presidential elections
that he would lose the popular vote and
it get worse every [__] time
every [__] time
can you imagine the shift
the shifts and the corners we could turn
in this country with him losing and
dragging every damn bat down ballot
candidate with him as the anchor do you
have any idea what kind of Corners we
could turn
we we could codify Roe v Wade I bet I
bet I bet
we could get the era
as the as the as an amendment
it's been ratified we just need to
change the the ratification stipulations
of the time limit that's it
think about the things that we could do
because these people are still [__]
hanging on to a loser
still hanging on to a loser so much so
that they can't even fight back against
him in their own primaries good good
[__] them they did this these are the
fleas they laid down with and these are
the fleas they wake up with every
[__] morning Chris Christie Ronda
santis do you remember that Chris
Christie's the one who got covered
because he was prepping Donald Trump to
beat Joe Biden
and Chris Christie says you goddamn
right I'll vote for Trump if he was the
nominee because he's the Republican
nominee
it's all right there right in front of
you folks
it's not it's not rocket surgery it
really isn't
it it isn't
I'm not saying these things because I'm
trying to predict something that isn't
going to happen and look like the
smartest man on earth
I'm just using the what is in front of
me and what is in front of me is their
narrative and their narrative is is that
the entire doj and FBI is all weaponized
by democrats by Joe Biden
and by Hunter Biden's laptop
to make sure that Trump doesn't come to
power
that's their narrative and that's what's
driving this primary and that's what
will give him the nomination no matter
what
no matter what
some people don't know what rocket
surgery is don't you know I mean Elon
does Rocket surgery every day don't you
know what Rockets archery is oh my God
thank you for joining us it's Friday
Friday Friday you know what Friday is
Friday is bonehead of the week in the
second hour you vote you decide who is
the bonehead of the week
me and my co-host Gabe Sanchez break it
down every single Friday in the second
hour I know sometimes we go along but
Gabe has a hard out today at the top of
the hour so we're really gonna have to
stick to two we're gonna have to do two
hours today it's gonna be two hour
Friday not three hour Friday two hour
Friday today with bone end of the week
don't forget to subscribe to the Tony
Michaels podcast here on YouTube that's
how you vote for Moon hand of the week
go to the community tab you can vote for
bonehead a week every single week you
can also vote on Twitter at Tony
Michaels pod and download every single
episode not just the Friday episodes
Monday through Friday on Apple Spotify
Google
here's what happens I do a little bit of
editing of the show right on the audio
side and then I post it every day to go
on the directories Apple Spotify Google
and there's a lot of them Stitcher
there's a bunch of directories that
people listen to the show on
but here's what happens
when you guys download
that on whatever directory whether you
download it on one or several we get
credit for it as a download
and it pushes our show into the
algorithm which is really cool so thank
you for all the downloads out there
whether you're just listening or you're
just downloading to help the show out
because it does it really does help and
let me tell you something else that I'm
impressed with over on Twitch it's it's
we're growing and growing and growing
over there and I I don't how exactly if
it's like organic at twitch or if it's
the people are have decided they want to
go watch over there because they like
the platform I'm not real sure tell us
tell us because yesterday
um who was it it was CB over there and
uh who else someone else said I think it
was a big step fan
um they were talking about at the end of
the show when we were going out and I
noticed it that they used to be the only
two over there on Twitch and it's true
there was only two three people that
would watch on Twitch at any given time
right now currently right now we have 62
viewers it doesn't sound like a lot but
that's a hell of a number of growth from
two three to sixty two that's a lot and
it's just been in the last few months
and we really appreciate all the growth
over there the other thing that's really
cool about twitch is that uh our
followers are free it's free to follow
you know it doesn't cost you a single
thing to go over to Twitch if you want
to check it out and follow us the Tony
Michaels podcast on Twitch you just go
to the Tony michaels.com all the links
are there for all the stuff uh but
what's really cool about twitch is
Amazon owns twitch
and Amazon if you have a Prime account
gives you one free subscription on
Twitch and what that does is it allows
you with no extra cost give your
favorite Creator on twist or your
favorite streamer whichever you call it
they normally call them streamers over
there on Twitch
um I I'm just an idiot on Twitch I'm
just an idiot on the internet I guess
but if you go over to if you link your
Amazon Prime account in your Twitch
account you can actually give us as as a
Creator and a streamer on Twitch that
one free subscription
to Amazon Prime and we get a few bucks a
month it's a really cool way for you
guys to monetarily support the show and
not cost you an extra nickel if you're a
prime subscriber so check that out just
go to the Tony michaels.com the
directions I think it's the fourth link
down it says link Amazon and twitch you
just link those two accounts you give us
your one free subscription you get with
your Prime account over on Twitch and we
get a couple bucks every month and you
have to renew it every month they don't
make it easy
and it only takes like three seconds it
really does you link it and then every
month you go on and you re-subscribe or
you resub whatever they call it over
there I don't know all the lingo on
Twitch and I know a lot of the people
want the emotes and stuff I'm gonna try
to work on that this weekend I promise
all you twitch users over there and the
twitch chat so thank you thank you so
much
um uh over there on Twitch for the
support so go follow us on Twitch it's
free and if you got an Amazon Prime
account do us a favor and subscribe with
your Amazon Prime account by linking it
to your Twitch account it gets us cup
bucks every month keeps us going here at
the Tony Michaels podcast because we're
not
we're not Soros funded here
unfortunately I would take soros's money
like a lot of people like oh it's Jordan
Soros funded like George seriously if
you want to send me money I'm down dude
whatever you want to do sent you I got
I'll give you my [__] mailbox number
you send a check aren't [__] you can
just put it directly in the bank account
I don't give a damn
I take sources money wouldn't you who
the [__] wouldn't take someone else's
money
[__] right Wingers would take soros's
money God damn it you ever seen these
grifters these Grifton [__] of
course they take soros's money and then
they'd be like oh and that that
[__] over there Sorrows funded
while they're getting somewhere else
money well it sets really on the right
wing works I don't even know that they
get funded by all kinds of outside
groups like these podcasts these
right-wing podcasts and [__] these weird
ones you're like who the [__] are these
people they're funded by Nazis they're
they're funded by Nazis yeah right-wing
Nazis and that's how they make their
shows we don't get that kind of [__]
that that's why they project that Soros
pays everyone because no one's paying us
no one I rely on you the audience and
you're the greatest audience in the
world you really are and let me tell you
something you guys are some of the most
engaged in the chat when guests come on
our show they love to watch you guys in
chat you are the funniest audience you
guys have the best comments you guys
support you support each other more each
other inside the chat than any other
chat I've ever seen the [__] fam is
the best fam it really is and even the
people here who are come here to hate
watch are they just love to hate me
they're still great in the chat and I
know there's some trolls out there but
even the trolls are great in the chat
sometimes so I really do appreciate you
guys and it's not just about you guys
supporting us with money
the reason why is because you can share
you can like this right now like if
you're on YouTube you can like it you
can share it
um you can you can put it out on social
media like every day you can take you
can take the YouTube link and go put it
on Twitter every single day now I tweet
it out and that's the YouTube link but
you can go tweet it out to all your
supporters on Facebook or you can you
can tweet it out on Facebook you can
post it on Facebook you can tweet it on
Twitter and you can share that link
around with anyone who you want and and
that helps out the show a lot because
not only does that give us backlinks to
the YouTube and a lot of people
yesterday because I mentioned that I was
gonna go off YouTube I'm not actually
gonna go up YouTube what I was what I
was trying to say
was that wasn't gonna Focus as much on
YouTube and promoting YouTube the reason
why is because YouTube doesn't promote
us they don't the platform doesn't it
doesn't help us keep the show going
other than it's very available and I
know a lot of people watch on TV and one
of the easiest ways to watch on TV is
with your YouTube app on your smart TV
so I'm never gonna stop streaming to
YouTube I doubt I highly doubt that
unless they absolutely will not let me
and they refuse to let me I probably I
probably won't
um but but what I was trying to say is
my focus on what platform we're actually
promoting because we've been we've been
building the YouTube channel for a long
time
and for over two years now
and YouTube I mean we've got almost 16
000 subscribers I think on YouTube
something like that 16 000 followers
something like that
which a lot of people don't think is
enough but you know it is what it is we
get uh we get anywhere between
on YouTube anywhere between 12 and 1300
people at any given moment
during the show we normally have 16 to
1800 people watching across platforms
rather it's on Twitch or Facebook
um Twitter doesn't really count and then
the reason why is because Periscope is
[__]
the only reason why I broadcast to
Twitter at all is to give you the
YouTube link that's it so I guess where
I'm going with this is maybe I wouldn't
put out the YouTube link as much more
like the twitch link or the Facebook
link because YouTube just doesn't
doesn't show us any any support they
don't they don't want to monetize this
they don't want us to monetize
um they don't they which only tells me
they don't want us to engage with our
audience which you guys engage back no
matter what so that's the challenge
we're up against we're not a huge
Channel and and and but again our
audience is is real I know you guys are
real and you guys are highly engaged and
it's it's really great to see that it's
not just in one spot but in several
spots uh where you guys are engaged
whether it be on
um Facebook or YouTube or Twitter or
twitch uh you guys are highly engaged
and I just want to thank everyone this
morning there's been several people that
have either resubscribed with their
Prime account out just in the last 10
minutes or um uh link their Prime
account to their Twitch account and gave
us that subscription so thank you so
much and thank you for all the follows
over there it's getting bigger and
bigger on Twitch so I wasn't I'm not
saying I'm gonna go off YouTube
I'm not saying I'm going off YouTube but
it's really hard to you know get excited
about YouTube to be quite honest with
you when they basically tell you to [__]
off it is it's hard it's difficult I'm
not gonna lie I'm not gonna lie YouTube
you bastards everyone stick around
we got Gabe Sanchez I gotta show you a
video remember we talked about uh Kim uh
Petrus Petrus is that her name she's a
she's a singer she sings Unholy with Sam
Smith now she's got a new um uh duet
with the cardi B and she's she's a
German artist she's German singer she's
gonna be on the swimsuit cover of Sports
Illustrated and they're really pissed
off they're so pissed off oh my God I
knew they would be and I got oh man I've
got a great video I got a great video
that I that I want to show you this
morning so stick around don't go
anywhere we'll be right back right after
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a MAG Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babel Maga
Edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon I was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the words that I'm struggling with I
chose Babble Mega Edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now I can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new Mega skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
[Music]
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
Friday you know what that means phone
head of the week
[Music]
already got the graphics loaded in we're
ready to go Folks at the top of the hour
all we got to do is get Gabe Sanchez on
the broadcast
be ready to go
um I told you there's a there's a clip I
want to show you here this morning this
is [__] hilarious oh my God they're
still losing their minds about Bud Light
a little bit
um and we're gonna talk about Tarjay
Tarjay our Target as some people know it
you know the store Target
um we're gonna talk about Target I
believe in the bonehead of the week but
they're still on this Bud Light thing oh
my God I went to a I went to a like a
small live concert thing last night and
um I was at the bar ordering a Bud Light
haha
ordering a Bud Light this is hilarious
so I'm at the bar I order a Bud Light I
don't normally drink beer but beer was
the fastest thing to drink because there
was a lot of people there wasn't many
places to get a drink so I and and you
had to have a special cup anyways
and just I don't normally I used to
drink beer a lot I don't drink beer as
much anymore
so it's the fastest thing for me to grab
and so I ordered Bud Light because I
usually would drink Bud Light or
Michelob Ultra I just like light beer I
like I like water in my beer what do you
want from me
just how it's [__] raised I guess I
was raised on um water beer anyways so I
ordered my light and I hear this guy
standing behind me and he's like oh
you're ordering a skirt with that beer
and I turn around look at it I said what
are you scared are you scared this beer
is gonna make you gay and he's like no
no I'm it's I don't think it's Gonna
Make Me Gay that's why I don't drink
it was hilarious this guy didn't know
what the [__] to say he had no idea what
to say when I turn around and I was
pouring it in my glass you know I'm
pouring in my glass
I was like what do you think this Beer's
gonna Turn You Gay
he got he got really upset he could tell
I was saying hey man you're a little
insecure there about your sexuality
fragile white man you're a little
insecure friend I just thought it was
funny because he's like what do you
order a skirt with that beer yes this is
great it's great it's a great time I
liked uh now again I didn't take it any
further than that because I wanted to go
listen to the music there was a great
band blings I want to listen to the
music I didn't I don't want to stand
around arguing with this [__] idiot
when he when he when he doesn't know the
beer doesn't turn you gay
oh man but uh
speaking of these fragile white men
last week we showed uh the swimsuit cut
was it last week or was it this week
Jesus Christ I can't remember
I can't remember anyways uh we were
talking about the 2023 swimsuit edition
of Sports Illustrated and they're gonna
have four people on the cover uh one of
them was Martha Stewart and we went and
looked at Martha Stewart's some of her
pictures from the swimsuit edition God
damn
Martha Stewart she's the [__] smoke
show I did not I didn't really I mean I
I didn't know that I knew she used to be
a model way back in the day and I know
she's got enough money to you know do
enough black surgery to look the way she
wants probably but Martha's oh God damn
Martha's good looking I mean she is
objectively right even if you're you
know not into that sort of thing you
still like damn she looks good but um
Kim Petras is that my saying that right
I think that's what what her name is I
don't know I don't I don't listen to
much pop music but anyways
uh Kim she's a German singer she sang
with uh Sam Smith and Unholy uh she's
gonna be on the swimsuit edition of
Sports Illustrated and it's really going
to confuse the [__]
add them in especially these [__]
fragile white in cells
um that are running around that don't
like boobs they don't like boobs they
don't like women they don't like sexy
women they think women should be covered
up head to toe it's really weird [__]
like honestly when I was a kid these
these [__] toxic men they [__]
loved boobs I mean they love well they
were [__] hollering and whistling at
women and [__] and I guess women were
just like hey we don't like that you're
not you're not sexy doing that and so it
really pissed them off it really got in
their fields that the toxic masculinity
isn't sexy anymore right like that's not
the picture of men it's not the picture
of men that women generally want they
don't want to be objectified dudes but
they want to objectify women and if they
can't objectify women then they want
them to cover from head to head to toe
that's what they want
it's kind of weird again I'm still
trying to get used to it because when I
was a kid that wasn't the case with
these folks it's different
but they turned a corner and they're all
in on Fascism and that's a tenement of
fascism is to if you can't objectify
women
to absolutely get to the handmaid's tale
as fast as possible you see that in a
lot of Middle Eastern countries I don't
know if you know that did you know that
that Middle Eastern countries have
right-wing ideology did you know that
they're theocracies huh that's kind of
weird it's just not Christian but it's a
theocracy hmm
I wonder if there's some sort of a
connection or pattern there I wonder if
that's the case if men just like to use
religion
to to oppress others
I wonder I don't know it could be
something to it but anyways back to the
swimsuit edition now we showed this let
me see if I can pull the uh the image up
and I'll show you the picture she's
[__] smoking hot on this thing
on this uh this picture
on this uh and then here it is
uh here's the swimsuit edition of Kim
here she is on the 2023 cover so here it
is Sports Illustrated Swimsuit 2023
game bedrooms okay
I think I'm saying that right I may not
be I don't know anyways cam here is on
the cover Sports Illustrated
she's a trans woman right now this is re
this would really piss off people
they're like oh man God you're
misgendering him no no I'm not listen
it's not it's not that hard to say him
or her him it's not that difficult and
really honestly if you get so [__]
upset if you get soap [__]
upset
about about what you call someone then
we should what me and Gabe Sanchez said
the other day we should [__]
misgender them to their [__] face and
they'd be like oh my God don't call me
that I'm I'm a man you don't call me a
woman well hey man I I'm just saying you
kind of look kinda you look kind of
feminine there buddy just like the guy
at the bar when I ordered the beer and
he's like there's a skirt come with that
beer that turn right away you think this
beer makes you gay and Turn You Gay
their friend
I mean
so Kim here is beautiful right that's
what the chat's in she's gorgeous she's
absolutely gorgeous she's absolutely
gorgeous now this is where it [__] them
up
okay and this is what I've talked about
for for eight years
is that this is what they're really
terrified of right this is what the guy
the guy at the bar he was he was talking
[__] on Bud Light who thought it would
be cute he thought oh he thought I'd be
real cute he thought I'd just whimper
away not say anything and not point out
his [__] insecurities of his sexual
orientation
because that's what they're doing
it's all the insecurity of their sexual
orientation because they see this and
they're like God damn I want to [__] Kim
that's what they think right that's what
they think they're like woo baby I would
like to have sex with Kim but then they
realize
realize that Kim is a trans woman
and that's where it starts to get
complicated and it gets complicated for
them more than Kim because Kim doesn't
give a [__] you think she cares
if millions of men are really mad that
she at one point in her life was a man
you think that you think that [__]
upsets her no she could probably give
two shits less about anyone who has that
opinion about her now she probably
definitely I would say doesn't want
bigots running around oppressing
people's rights I would say that's
probably a fair statement I don't want
people doing that and I'm not and I'm
I'm a cisgender man
I'm one of them white dudes crackers
here's the thing
is that these fragile white incels they
get so [__] weirded out by the fact
that they are attracted to uh a woman
beautiful woman like Kim that at one
point used to be a man and they're so
insecure in their sexuality because I I
don't actually believe that maybe
they're homosexual because that's one
thing they don't understand about sexual
orientation or sexuality or sex in
general
is that it's fluid right like it's a
spectrum there's some people that are
gay there's some people that are
straight there's some people that are a
little bit of both there's some people
that are more one than the other
and generally speaking most people don't
even know exactly what you are until you
I don't know have experience in that
area
so it confuses them right they get
confused it doesn't mean that they're
that they're trying to run from
something that's deep down inside them
that's closeted I mean it it possibly
it's a really
um
it's a pretty guaranteed bet of the
projection
but who gives a [__] we don't care we I
could give a [__] less if that guy at
the bar behind me that was talking [__]
about Bud Light
because he thinks Bud Light is a gay
beer and and it really is a bigot he's a
bigot he hates [__] gay people is
what it is he hates [__] gay people
he hates the lgbtq community he's doing
it out of his hatred he says that [__]
at a bar to someone like me because of
his hatred
and he probably didn't know
he probably didn't know that I knew the
deal about Bud Light right that's
probably the other thing because
probably what he was doing was to try to
let me know that Bud Light is one of
them gay beers as if beer has a sexual
orientation right
but that's the [__] up thing in their
minds that's the [__] up thing in
their minds they think anything that has
to do with lgbtq anything is sexual
right they can they get it all twisted
around to get it all confused
because they think anything absolutely
anything that is associated rather it's
the words the rainbow the anything they
think it is sexual inherently and it's
it's it's not
it's not when you say the word when
you're a man and you're married to a
woman and you say my wife it doesn't it
doesn't mean it's sexual okay that or I
am dating a woman that doesn't
inherently make it sexual okay you got
it are you are you on the same page
there friend
so just because a woman
says that she has a wife doesn't make it
sexual that's your problem
that's a you thing that you're doing
bonehead
you're making it sexual so when you look
at this picture
and you get a boner because Kim is hot
or you get your feels up or you get
fluttery on the inside or in that
special place of yours
it's not because
you're gay or you're part of the LGB are
you supporting trans people it's because
you think Kim here is objectively
[__] smoking hot which she is
she is what are you gonna what the [__]
are you gonna do about it man you people
you people are really [__] upset that
the little mermaid is now black a
fictional character has changed skin
colors changed
you can't wrap your minds around any of
this stuff and it's okay we get it
you're dumb [__] we understand this
stuff it's gonna take you a while to
catch up to I don't know
2023. we get it we got it
but I want to show you a clip here
oh my God I found this glitch I don't
know who this [__] is I have no
idea who Anna Perez is no clue don't
know Patriot takes post of this and and
this scumbag oh hey look there's Gabe
Sanchez not not that scumbag he's not
the scumbag I was talking about
I mean you know I was talking about do
you know who Anna Perez is I don't know
who this [__] I didn't I don't know
who that is until you sent me the uh
because I wanted to talk about this week
it's hilarious I have no idea who that
is did you hear my story about the Bud
Light last night
no what happened okay so I was at like a
music event it was an outside event see
but see it was like a gate so the liquor
license was like in the street you know
so you had to have a special cup to
drink out of right the only company you
drink at him anyways it's special liquor
license that sort of thing but but we
could go in the bar and there was some
bars set up outside but the lines were
long so I went into this one bar and I
go to the bar to order a a beer because
I was drinking beer last night which is
not normally my thing but it was the
fastest thing to get to drink right yeah
yeah right yeah so I I ordered a bud
line and I'm pouring it in the special
cup at the bar and the guy behind me
says did you order a skirt with that
beer and I turned around and look at him
I said what are you you're scared this
Beer's gonna turn you gay
he got real ready yeah oh he's he didn't
know what the [__] said oh I just don't
I just don't like that they're that
they're promoting that beer that's what
he said something like promoting that I
I don't know I was like what are you
scared of Beer's gonna look really funny
and then you know I think I said when I
walked away I said man it makes me real
horny for men when I walked away I took
a big drink makes me real horny man
never never wanted a dick more in my
life what the idea you are weird that
you think that there's that only people
who wear skirts are gonna order Bud
Light if the vaccine has a you know 5G
in it then the Bud Light has just gay in
it that's probably true I mean what
where in the where in the Brewing
process do you think bloodline actually
puts in the game like probably it's a
there's like a oh we only put the Hops
in the barley and the you know except
they're like it's it at night where do
they like the glittering at night at
night there's a secret gay elf and comes
in and he throws it into one of the
silos
but it's it's your glitter or what is it
I don't know I have no idea it's just
like
because it's a weird thing because I was
standing they had another beer bar they
had another beer bar but the line was
pretty long and it closed that's why I
had to go to the other bar right then
another beer bar and there were some
people standing there and they had you
know Michelob Ultra Bud Light Bush light
I mean like all Anheuser products right
because uh it's Missouri yeah Hawaii
right it was kind of weird you know how
they're delivered on [__] Clydesdales
too man right so I heard one guy say no
no don't give me a Bud Light I'm not
drinking that give me a Busch Light and
I looked at him and I said dude it's the
same thing man what like I'm not I'm not
giving my money to the people who
support trans people give me give me a
bush slide I'll I'll actually support
the same company just same beer just
different label whatever whatever
I would challenge anyone if they see
someone order or rather not order uh and
and they unwanted that gay Bud Light or
whatever or whatever the [__] they're
gonna say be like oh so you don't
believe trans people are real people
like just out in the oven just like so
you don't believe these are real people
huh yeah well I mean it totally shows
off their bigotry like this clip here oh
my God have you did you watch the clip I
watched part of it it's like one minute
but before we okay okay I have something
to say about Miller Lite but we could
watch this yeah go ahead go ahead no
okay
oh you're from up North my bloodline you
gotta get in your Northern beer no no no
commercial that they that they're
bitching about the commercial they're
bitching about with uh Eliza Glazer
right but that commercial is from March
during women's History Month no no no
you're acting like that they found this
thing and they're just getting off I
don't know cultured up turbo family
really got all upset about it turbo fam
you mean Ian Ian miles Chong well you
know why they're really pissed off about
this because we're going to talk about
um this Bud Light thing again in the
[__] bone-in of the week because we
we're going to talk about Tarjay Target
as some know it they think they can but
they can't think but like Target which
they didn't Bud Light Bud Light anyways
again I would stand in line and the
guy's like don't get me a Bud Light [__]
that queer beer I want Bush life like
dude it's the same it's this it's the
same [__] man same money going the same
[__] just because Dylan
Mulvaney didn't have a bush and a light
you're gonna order the bush it doesn't
make it would be funny if Dylan Mulvaney
bought all of the Anheuser-Busch
products and then we're like I don't
know much about like because she's such
a feels like I don't even know much
about beer but they sent me this beer
kind of thing like my urine transition
right and I would laugh if she took a
photo like no photos on her face of her
face on the cans obviously but I would
love if she took a photo with all every
single beer product out there ever
everyone you know what [__] it every
every alcohol [__] every whiskey
tequila vodka maybe it's a good idea
maybe that's a good idea maybe we could
um partner with Dylan and just see if we
can
get her to take pictures with every
single [__] bottle
serious the whole oh everything Hard
Lemonade the owl all of it all of it
just [__] with then they can't drink
they wouldn't even be able to drink it
might kill the American economy though
I'm not gonna lie it might kill the
American economy but it also there's a
part of me what's like wait what would
these people be like sober well that is
true that is true well I don't know if
this Anna Perez is drinking I don't know
who the hell she is to be quite honest I
have no idea I have no idea but she's
got one of those [__] she got the
snake
yeah something the snake cutting pieces
one Whatever whatever that flag is I
don't know well it doesn't take long for
you to catch on
um to her bigotry here right because
she's just oh
Join or Die that's what it is oh yeah
she's not just uh transphobic she's also
fat phobic too she hates fat people
apparently let's let's listen this you
talk about a scumbag this one Takes the
Cake obviously the biological fat woman
is still a better option than a
biological male parading as a woman what
what was that did she say biological fat
person
yeah is that is that where they're at is
that they have to I mean seriously
people don't run around identifying as
biologically fat or are trans fat people
what the [__] is she talking about why
why are they so obsessed with people's
identity they are the ones who are
massively obsessed so do they not like
adjectives anymore either like they
don't like pronouns in a band we're
gonna ban all words
you know and they say uh say it in your
own words it's a George Carlin joke he
says
that's my own words like I I'm using
words that everyone else is using okay
well sort of sort of yeah I know not
really but you know sort of all right
let's we get the meaning right exactly
even when I [__] them up let's listen to
all the other bigotry that she pukes up
into this microphone it's [__] wild
[__] listen whatever because a year
passed it became normalized that we were
at the very least not going to advertise
healthy fertile women okay so now they
keep a step further and showed you a man
who obviously isn't even a woman on the
covers see that's not I don't know if
you just seen the picture of Kim she is
not obviously a man
that she's not obviously a man I'm sorry
I know that that that's what they want
to paint the picture of all trans women
but Kim uh Patrick is is that how you
say it Petrus Petra's pet I think it's
Kim Petrus Petrus wait wait wait wait
here let me know you're gonna you're
gonna see if you Kim Petrus if that is
how you say it she is obviously a really
smoking hot woman I know I you know you
can say what you want but I mean and
she's a trans woman trust P trust
because it is
well but I've from Missouri so I says
the Patriots okay like Peach Tree dish
okay no no no never mind I'm actually on
her uh I'm on her YouTube channel and
she says
I was right the hillbilly from Missouri
you know all I had to watch was uh you
know three seconds into her 19 second
welcome to my channel Kim Petrus video
right
Amanda says I'm a biologically [__] I'm
biologically [__]
oh God you're the best in the world okay
let's let's continue with uh
whoo this biological vile human being
here let's listen see how that works I
bet now you wish you had the big fatty
on the cover right but now even that's
been accomplished so they're gonna move
on to putting a man on the cover see
what I mean see how that works okay so
you follow she's saying she's saying
they get you used to having fat people
and then and then it'll confuse I I
don't understand why she thinks that
it's only men buying the swimsuit
edition or Sports Illustrated it's not
only men and it's not only but I mean it
also
was there a a fat person on there I I
mean who knows what I mean again she's
saying that Kim petrol seriously
not obviously who the [__] cares right
that's true
I'll tell you they do what they want
they put whoever they want on there
you know what you know what they say
Gabe about about someone that's got a
little extra meat on them
in the sack you know what they say I I
don't know you tell me more cushion for
the pushing okay let's go let's go let's
go to uh uh Anna Perez's bigotry here
listen to our logic here because what
she's saying is hey they get used to fat
people you're used to fat people and
then they put them obviously a man which
it's not obviously a man it's obviously
a woman on the cover and then what
happens Anna what happens when they do
that what happens if they put a fatty on
the cover and for another year we'd
probably just shrug our shoulders maybe
I wouldn't have even done a show about
it because they're slowly rewiring you
to to find those things attractive
that's slowly becoming normal so what
does that equate to well over time you
know men will start to find all of those
things normal and start to try and
reproduce with those people that'll
become The New Normal fat
okay so her now her aim here is
depopularization right that this is the
left's
uh way of depopularizing the Earth or
some [__] that and what she's scared of
is that men here's what she's scared of
is that men are Gonna Wanna [__] trans
women and I hate to break it to Anna and
I actually tweeted a PornHub this
morning to try to see if PornHub could
clue Anna in right there's a lot of
dudes out there [__] trans women I
mean it's it's a thing that happens and
it's been happening for a long time this
isn't new stuff it's not new it's not
new I don't know why Anna is so scared
that men will want to have sex with
trans women I don't understand I also
there I'm gonna go I'm gonna go on a
lemons well I'm gonna say this and I
hope no one gets mad at me
so you know how we measure whether
you're in shape or fat right the
standard though I think it's Antiquated
and doesn't really have an indication of
how you are health-wise is your BMI
right your best your uh body mass index
and you're like oh well if you're this
tone you have this much weight then this
is where you are but that's no
indication to be like oh well actually
you're this percentage fat versus this
percentage muscle right and I and I know
you know
there's a part of me that says if you
were in again I want to apologize this
is I'm I'm not body shaming or anything
here but what I'm saying is if you were
to take someone because I went online
and I looked up Enterprise because I was
like I don't know who this is and I look
for photos now I wouldn't be surprised
if
you were to take a BMI of someone like
Anna and on the chart it says oh well
this person is a little bit overweight
right now again I don't think that's the
right way to measure someone's health or
weight right in terms of what we go by
it's really stupid but the idea that
someone would attack other women for
being overweight or fat or whatever
adjectives she wants to use you know
it's throwing
it I want to ask you I'm going to ask
you are you saying that Anna is thick is
that what you're saying I'm not I'm not
saying she is oh okay
in the video I'm saying you can't see
she's just from here right right and I
mean from here down I'm kind of thick
I don't I don't give a you know what I'm
saying I know what I am saying [__] is
if Anna Perez wants to go by actual
standards that are used to classify
someone as one of those adjectives right
then I would say that there's a
possibility that she could like any what
else could fall in that area where you
put that adjective of this person's
overweight this person's fat right again
not saying I believe that but the idea
that we're going to body shame someone
you you better be very very
Penny here says on YouTube she said you
are the best audience in the world she
says she's sick from the neck
so what I'm saying is I'm not being I'm
I'm not and again I I just want to
apologize I'm not trying to be shallow
I'm just saying I'm just saying that if
she were to go by the same metrics right
something on there that I don't really
believe is is accurate could also Place
her in that category I'm not saying she
is but I'm also saying like we shouldn't
be really attacking someone
here's the thing here's the thing that
Anna doesn't realize because she's a
[__] vile piece of trash is that that
beauty is in the eye of the beholder
okay and a lot of times a lot of times
it when you love someone and and
obviously not a lot of people have shown
Anna much love too bad she didn't get a
[__] hug as a kid or something but
here's the thing is that love love a lot
of times isn't a physical attraction
yeah sometimes it is sometimes it is
because again beauty is in the eye of
the older some folks like little scrawny
people they like a skinny [__]
they like a skinny dude right I've seen
a lot of women like a skinny dude some
of them like a chubby some [__] some
men like a big thick girl some men like
real skinny girl again
why in the [__] are we running around
saying what is beauty and what is not
right when the the most obvious thing is
the person who is looking through their
eyes and their experience that's the
beauty and I think wait wait wait hold
on are you telling me that that who you
love or or who you decide to have a
relationship with is all preference oh
well that is something that is a liberal
idea that you've got guys I'm just
saying man it seems like something
that's a liberal idea you got going and
you know what's what's and again this is
Their Fear right this is Their Fear this
is the guy at the bar who said the [__]
about bloodline to me this is this is
Matt Walsh we're going to talk about
Matt Walsh here in a little bit this is
Anna's fear this is anyone fear who
looks at that swimsuit edition of Kim
and and and can't get over of how good
she looks and can't get over that she at
one point in her life was not she was
she was he and they can't get over it
the reason why is because they're
they're terrified
terrified
terrified that maybe just maybe they
find something that they've been told
that shouldn't attract them to someone
attracts them to someone and it's
terrifying to them and the reason why is
because most most of these cisgender
white fragile men have lived in a bubble
their entire a privilege bubble their
entire life but most of them almost
every single one of them and until they
get outside that bubble they really
can't focus on anything else but but
their own sexuality and this is why it's
the weird thing where they sexualize
everything that is lgbtq
because and it's weird because like when
I introduced my wife I'm like hey this
is my wife people aren't like whoa
that's sexual because we're we're
married she's my wife I'm man she's a
woman but there's nothing inherently
sexual about her being married to me
other than every once while we [__] you
know what I mean but I mean we don't
have whoa Tony we don't have to [__] we
don't have to though that seems a little
bit Progressive for uh conservatives but
here's the crazy part is is a woman says
my wife
my wife oh that's sexual you're
sexualizing what sexualizing what no you
you are sexualizing it you are
sexualizing what that is because you
can't get out of your brain two women
are [__]
that's awesome that's what they're
thinking right that's the process that
they go through now Robin here says on
Twitch he says BMI has caused many
issues people have different body types
we're not one size fits all world yeah
that's absolutely correct I saw someone
else who was talking about you know it's
just a you know and I brought up BMI
because I say that it's it's an improper
it's a [__] measurement measure of
muscle demand like muscle to to to to
Fat like
like I said I don't think BMI is the
accurate way to go and I you know
there's a lot of love for dude there's a
chubby people in the chat people some I
saw someone else say you know Different
Strokes for different folks right it's
you love who you love you and prefer
what you prefer and you do what you want
to do you know some of the cutest
couples in the world when you see them
out and they're like they're like giving
a lot of PDA it's when the guy's like
skinny as a [__] toothpick and he's
got him a big woman and they love each
other something else
no no that's some of the cutest [__] in
the [__] world when when she like
she's got him underneath her arm and
carrying him around and [__] like a
teddy bear and he just loves the [__]
out of it he's enjoying every [__]
moment of it there's nothing else going
on in the world but him and her baby and
that's there's nothing wrong with that I
mean it's so liberal you know I mean
obviously like humans were were built
for
um I mean dealing with other humans I
mean being with other humans but also
outside of like you know Dolphins were
the only [__] uh creatures out there
that are [__] for [__] for pleasure
so right but also like you can only you
can I mean some people might be asexual
and that's their thing right but the uh
the the other side of it is like
you can only hope that in your life
you're like man I hope I find someone
right whether they're a man or woman or
whatever right you could be pansexual
you buy sexual trans whatever like
whatever whatever you you feel like
right
um
Credo vision is saying Jack Sprat
syndrome is that what I'm talking about
the the real skinny guy who who loves uh
I mean and I'm not talking just like a A
thick one I'm talking like you know he's
like five foot nothing and she's like
six five you know what I mean I don't
know I've never heard that that's some
of the cutest [__] I've ever seen in my
life and I I just can't help just yeah
that is a nurse an English language
Nursery Rhyme well yeah what is the
meaning
oh it's it's Jack Sprat is used to refer
to someone who's of small stature oh
okay okay there's nothing wrong with it
there's nothing wrong with it you know
what I don't have anything wrong with
Jack Sprat like in the um a little small
woman either I'm just saying I think
it's I think it's kind of cute when
you're out and you see a a little bitty
guy with a big old confidence that's the
other thing too I want to be able to get
theirs man that's right be with the
confidence
because here's the thing Tony we're not
here very long like in the grand schema
thing we're here for a short period of
time and part of that time you're still
trying to figure out yourself and then
once you hopefully figure out yourself
then you're like I hope someone else
knows me and understands me and loves me
for who I am after I figure out myself
right and at that time you're like most
of the time I spend either you know
sleeping in bed
or I'm working so it's like I gotta find
someone that I can fill those moments
with to make my [__] life special
right
I'll now they're typing in the Jack
spread that story
go to bonehead of the week because I
want to talk about this target thing
because it kind of continues uh with
this nonsense this [__] weird stuff
where where people are sexualizing
people because they their their lgbtq
because of their sexual we don't we
don't automatically sex I mean we do
sexualize
straight women like a [__] have
for years that's why they're mad about
that Middle Light commercial that you
were talking about
um but Matt Walsh I'm just going to tell
you it's Matt Walsh is in this bone of
the week he's such a [__] scumbag man
these people are the amount listed man
the amount of Real Estate
that the lgbtq community takes up in
in in in the Republican party's mind is
crazy like I'm surprised that they can
actually that might explain that might
explain why they're not able to function
like why Jim Jordan might be like uh
short-circuiting when he's like proven
wrong on the rules by Goldman right but
you you find these Republicans who spend
so much of their mental energy and I
just said it a moment ago life is
[__] short okay you should be
enjoying it why are you spending all of
your [__] waking time you get out of
bed you think about it you go to sleep
you think about it right like you fall
asleep maybe you dream about I don't
know but these Republicans are so
obsessed that they spend so much mental
capacity though might be limited and
also physical energy
to spread hate and attack these people
and also visualize them in a sexual way
to all of these things that no one was
like no one ever thought of that man
you're the only one who thought of that
and you said it you might be onto
something there maybe because there's
not enough space inside their brain
and when they get that when they get the
lgbtq meeting in there it just takes up
all the space that's available and it's
not a month it's not a lot of space
right I mean yeah
when they start when they start
attacking either you know for uh with
regards to dumb policies or uh
marginalized communities or whoever it
might be right I think there's a limited
capacity of processing power in their
brain we'll go with that and then also
when you're like okay I'm really gonna
[__] Max this [__] out and I'm gonna
start thinking about how I can attack
these lgbtq plus community members and
say that you're not human you shouldn't
be able to go to the bathroom here I
won't address you as your preferred
pronoun because that's [__] gay or
whatever they say or I'm not gonna do
this I'm not I'm gonna basically they
they go out
into the world and actively look for
things that could be
not straight
and people are like dude no one ever no
one ever made that connection yeah why
are you why are you thinking that why
are you aware that they're scared of
rainbows why are you an adult man who's
married and has children and this is
what you [__] think about right it's
kind of weird [__] problem bro kind
of weird kind of weird well let's let's
dive into a bone in the week don't go
anywhere we're gonna get to bone of the
week right after this break
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker Convoy
there's Tammy by the time we reach DC
White was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way
we got plenty of Slim Jims
skull
near run out of Natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
Circle the city again
Bob
dear Bob I'm fixing to send you some
more of them Doritos you like the red
bag not the live love and blue one
in your absence I discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and I
even seen my cousin Brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
yours Tammy
[__] um
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show it's Friday
we're in the second hour
we gotta get to it you gotta get right
to it you gotta go straight bonehead of
the week where you vote you decide who
is the bonehead of the week we break it
down here every single Friday bonehead
of the week
bonehead of the week oh boy do we have
Simone heads let's get straight into it
should we start we want to start the
music yeah you're limited on time right
yeah but the music is only so long okay
let's play it just you the goddamn music
[Music]
[Applause]
the music is pretty [__] swell isn't
it it's pretty good it's great it's
great it's good you know I was able to
find a tune that I think perfectly
matched these trials uh these these
Petty children uh whatever you want to
call them right well um let's start out
let's see who the bonehead of the week
contestants were Marjorie Taylor green
come on down uh governor governor weirdo
Ron Ron putting fingers to santis and
Jim I don't report sex crimes Jordan I
want to start with Governor weirdo he
keeps talking about whoa woke and woke
and woke this and woke that mother woke
this and man oh my god did you hear that
crazy came up with this morning I know
this isn't the reason why he's on the
phone
oh my god let's play it here let's show
the audience trying to he's trying to
win those people back right it's weird
let's listen
falchism was destructive
root in this country ever again how many
times can I say faucism in the same
statement about faucism
are you [__] me [__] idiots
because
because you've got fauci who worked
there at previous administrations
Democratic administrations Republican
administrations it's almost like there
was a person that put fauci in place
that was a republican but I don't know
you know what his name was do you know
what his name was
does it start does it sound like a beer
huh yeah sure go ahead
Bush
do you know the other thing about falchi
is they hated
in the 80s and 90s they hated AIDS and
they stigmatized people with AIDS
did you know
the one person the virologist that is
really responsible
for helping in the AIDS
damn it Tony don't tell me do you know
who it is don't tell me do you know what
the tenement of fauchism is
is [__] ridiculous faucism really
Rhonda santis look I I don't know if you
heard this this morning Chris Christie
is supposed to be getting in the
president's race Ron dude man
I know you're on bone end of the week
and you didn't win
man do yourself a [__] favor listen
to me just listen
get in the [__] race dude Chris Chris
not only are you gonna be taking Flack
from Donald Trump Chris Christie is
going to [__] eat you like a Twinkie
[__] you out and flush you down the
goddamn toilet dude have you ever met
Chris Christie Chris Christie is gonna
tear him to shreds tear him the shreds
Rhonda Sandy you are [__] buddy you are
[__] [__] [__] and to think that Chris
Christie's gonna directly go after
Donald Trump immediately I mean he will
he's not scared to because Chris Kersey
doesn't give a [__] really
but to think that Chris Christie isn't
going to get the number two spot by
absolutely [__]
obliterating Ron DeSantis you people
aren't don't know how elections work you
don't know how politics works you don't
know how primaries work Chris Christie
is if he gets in the race he's gonna go
balls deep into Mickey Mouse well Mickey
Mouse's enemy so that's another thing
that's the reason why Rhonda Santos was
really on the bonehead wasn't it was
Mickey Mouse is that what it was he's
winning he's he's Mickey Mouse is
winning the war against Ronda it's
really Bob Iger Bob Iger
to the to the detriment of Floridians um
they're going to lose about 2 000 jobs
and about a billion dollars of
investment from Disney because Bob Iger
has told Rhonda Santos in Florida they
can go [__] themselves oh you want to
[__] with us cool we'll take our money
someplace else [__] you suck it [__]
and you know what's crazy here I'm gonna
show you this this is [__] nuts so
you got this sycophant
um I forget this guy's [__] name John
cardillo we I think he was on yeah he
gets [__] owned all the time he's the
same guy who I think maybe a few months
ago was like guys I figured out antifa
was at January 6th and he played the
video of both of Walter Peter and Walter
as they were going to they were doing
satire mock the Jan six insurrectionist
and then they released that footage on
their own onto YouTube and you know who
got so pissed off I think it was Newsmax
actually put up a uh a a a a a takedown
request on YouTube because they're like
they came in and they claimed that they
were part of Newsmax and we don't want
to allow people giving a bad name to us
even though we spread conspiracies
but it was the idea that
that uh that that's this guy and this is
not the first time I've seen him do
other [__] where it's like dude you face
planted this is not what you're thinking
[__] man here's what he says here's what
he tweeted 22 hours ago after this
announcement that Disney was not going
to invest a billion that's right a
billion with a [__] B in Florida he
says Disney won't move 2 000 workers to
Florida so Florida won't get 2 000 blue
voters Disney's not gonna pack people up
and move them there you [__] idiot he
says another Rhonda Santos win I said
here's what I said I said sick burn
dummy way to own the lids by creating
Less jobs you people are dumber than dog
[__]
how don't they know how jobs in States
work
so when General Motors are our Ford our
our Toyota or anyone builds a factory to
build cars anywhere Tesla they're not
like all right everybody get on a
[__] plane we're all going to this
state over here that's not how it works
but also not only the idea that that
they're like all right Disney Disney
decides to go afterwards like all right
who's gonna vote Democrat right right
they're like we're gonna find 2 000
political operatives to go work in
Disney and then ship them into Florida
you all like the also
you think 2 000 votes is going to make a
difference in Florida I mean maybe in a
County
but at the same time like
your idea that 2000 blue votes blue
votes that how are you are people
getting screened to be like what is your
political preference
like is that the thing that they have to
go in they they want to screen people
because of their political preference
they want to extreme people it makes no
sense Tony and that is
yeah well
um you know what else makes no sense Jim
Jordan being the chairman of the
Judiciary Committee why is he the
chairman not only that why does why it
doesn't does he exist that is true
um but why the [__] does he think
whistleblowers that are paid by Trump
and his allies whistleblowers why the
[__] does he think this
um we we watched this the other day it's
not the flex you think it is bro right
it just isn't it isn't but here here is
Daniel Goldman picking Jim Jordan's
whistleblowers apart and really honestly
this is the bone-headed clip that makes
Jim Jordan more boneheaded than any of
the other clips and the reason why is
because this face planted immediately no
one takes seriously political operatives
paid to be quote whistleblowers give me
a [__] break
well let's let's watch a couple
different questions uh we established
earlier credibility matters uh certainly
for Witnesses who appear
um before us uh Mr Boyle do you know who
cash Patel is
I do uh have you received any money from
cash Patel or his organization I have
um when you previously met with the
majority members and or majority staff
of this committee was Cash Patel present
with for that meeting no
uh to your knowledge has cash Patel ever
spoken to the committee members on your
behalf
not that I
that you know of was anyone present for
your previous meetings with committee
members and staff on the majority uh
that were not members of this committee
or staff of this committee my Council
your Council anyone else
I don't think so are you uh is Cash
Patel helping you uh Finance your
Council
not that I'm aware of
and Mr Friend what about you do you know
cash Patel as well
yes and did you receive any money from
cash Patel
she gave me a donation last November a
donation yes
are you a charitable organization
definitely suspended man trying to feed
his family and just reached out to me
and said he wanted to give me
um for you did he have any uh was he
present for any of your meetings with
committee members or staff no
and how many times did you meet with the
committee members or staff prior to your
transcribed interview I never met with
them prior to my transcription did you
speak to them on the phone yes
okay this is all right so you you spoke
to them on the phone yes I spoke to them
on the phone corresponded uh did you
provide documents yes I gave them my
written uh declaration
did they ask you uh whether they could
share that with the minority
I don't know at the time I don't believe
they were actually in the majority
did they ask you whether they could
share the documents
I don't remember if they did or didn't
um okay if you're sitting here wondering
like okay so these people aren't
whistleblowers and then if you're
wondering what are they even
whistleblowing for you got it you got it
the that's the exact reason why Jim
Jordan is on the bonehead of the week
list and why he's irrelevant why he's
not good at Judiciary at all no one
gives a [__] why these people are even
whistleblowers and what their
whistleblower is for because they're not
they're paid political operatives to say
what they need to say so that they can
put it in committee so they can act like
it's some sort of weaponization of the
government and it's not now if you
really want to know what these
whistleblowers are is the Mr Friend
there and um Debbie Wasserman Schultz
really picks him apart and I wish we had
more time to show that but Debbie
Wasserman Schultz fits him apart of why
he didn't not what does not work for the
FBI anymore right he doesn't because he
was [__] fired because he's he was
derelict in his duty was he was he also
involved in I don't know an Insurrection
well see that's the thing that's the
thing is it feels like to me feels like
to mean these political operatives not
only not only are paid political
operatives but they're also treasonous
pieces of [__] right and and it's really
funny how Republicans are like we're not
treasonous hey bring those bring those
[__] Traders in here we'll make them
whistleblowers we'll pay them so that
they can say they're whistleblowers
folks the reason why you have no idea
who these whistleblowers are what
they're blowing the whistle on is
because it doesn't matter because
they're not really whistleblowers and
Daniel Daniel Goldman did it in in two
minutes two minutes and seven seconds he
absolutely destroyed any chance that
Republicans Jim Jordan cash Mattel or
Donald Trump have to spin this narrative
that there are whistleblowers out there
not pay political operatives to
weaponize the government in the
Judiciary Committee Against the truth
so [__] Jim Jordan uh to be quite Frank
thanks I wanna I also wanna uh Roderick
that says here uh cash Patel doesn't he
look like Sammy Davis Jr you're thinking
of another interesting Trader that's
Ollie Alexander he's the one who has the
dirt on Margaret Taylor green right and
also turned out to be a pedophile hmm
it's really weird crazy it's really
weird how all those things kind of mix
in there and mix in there
um so let's let's do this uh I want to
go to the dishonorable mention first
okay and then we'll go to the alpha cook
um because I think we'll spend more time
on the alpha than we will in the winter
because the audience didn't let us down
again uh on the winner you guys know
exactly who it is it's not complicated
she's on the pole she's winning that
[__] undefeated but let's go to the
dishonorable mention first who is this
character on designer mention we didn't
we didn't really know her name until
recently yeah so it probably like I want
to say like maybe a month or so ago
um it was really kind of a small story
wouldn't it right at the beginning it
was a small story and her name is her
mate and her name is uh representative
Trisha is it them caught them [__]
care she's a traitor right she so she
was elected as a pro-choice Democrat
in North Carolina right she switched her
party a few weeks ago
and the only people that really were
making a big deal about it were kind of
right Wingers because everyone else was
like okay yeah all right some people
brought it up on the left and they
brought the fact that the idea
of because people are like oh [__] can
you like expel her can you take her away
she literally just got into office and
now she's turning within like you know a
couple few months of her being in office
like we're we're switching now or
whatever her party affiliation like what
could be the call like what could be the
reason uh what could be the effects that
she could do and ultimately they were
like there's no way to take her out in
terms of her position she's in there now
and she doesn't have to kind of turn
back around and say I'm uh I'm you know
I lied to you because that's what she
did she ran she did she she she did what
George
Santos did to his rights lied to him
[__] lying about who he was what it
what he was I mean she's definitely she
definitely reminds me of um other you
know there's a double quote-unquote
Democrats in the Senate right we've got
Kirsten cinema right uh we've got uh Joe
manchin
um the idea that
that you can have people that I mean
like in well Kirsten Cinema we'll just
say is she's more along the lines of
this situation she went from Democrat to
Independent but
you know there is something to be said
about what is the vetting process like
here right like we have these people who
claim to run under certain policies and
claim to have certain ideologies that
would fall under the umbrella of that
party and then you know within a short
period of time of you know being elected
or re-elected into office you have them
switching their affiliation to say huh
okay so all that stuff that I told you
guys or all that stuff that I said I was
I'm not actually that I'm actually a con
man right woman well because here's
here's the stakes here because yes it
seems like she aligned to her
constituents to get on a democratic
ticket to get elected as a Democrat and
then switch her party
um because she lied about her views and
lied about her actual ideology on these
subjects and what she was going to do
for those voters when they voted for her
because here's the ramifications
um in in North Carolina the governor
vetoed a bill that would ban Women's
Health Care I don't need to go go any
further than that it would ban Women's
Health Care and their access to health
care now
this Teresa cotham decided to switch
parties and she was the vote the key
vote to overturn that veto to ban
Women's Health Care in North Carolina
not only that there's more votes coming
and those votes she's going to be the
key vote and and overturning some of
those key policies here's a video uh
Michael Hyland of wncn it's a local news
station there in North Carolina and
here's a video of him questioning her uh
about her vote let's listen
you should be willing to take just a
couple questions about the vote last
night
when would you like to talk about it
there's one question that a lot of
people have though is how you reconcile
to vote with your public statements in
the past being in support of abortion
rights
you said that people need to be
unbelievering in their support of
abortion rights do you feel like you
stop
and I've told you this now about eight
times so thank you does it feel like
she's talking in slow motion it feels
like it to me hi I got it slow this clip
down at all maybe oh what if this may
okay hold on conspiracy theory we should
have like a conclusive
conspiracy just to warn people yeah
we're just talking out our ass right now
I'm just making totally just making sure
what if what if right the way that she
this is the best part of the show when
we when he's back yeah she goes you know
I've I've asked you now uh eight times
to uh not not not talk to me anymore and
I'm just here to reveal that I'm a
[__] alien I think that she also she
could be like for some sort of [__]
Android like like that's like Rhonda
santis yeah this is like Mike Pence
somewhere like we had always like oh
what's this oh it's it's doppelganger
you got this type you know she's like oh
my God I'd love to go back and look at
archive footage of her talking to see if
this is actually true or not in terms of
like her speaking pattern but there's a
part of me that says
she could be an Android and she's
pretending to be human she's just
wearing a skin suit that's it I mean
just a little fascist alien and a big
you know what she you know what she
reminds me of
um have you watched the show euphoria no
okay well for anyone in the audience for
anyone in the audience who's watched
Euphoria in the second season there's a
drug dealer lizard people there's a drug
dealer in the second season which I'm
blanking on her name right now but she's
this like little white kind of fragile
woman okay and she's super
[Laughter]
I can't our audience
she's the handmade Terminator so in the
show in the show Euphoria which I
definitely recommend anyone anyone if
you if you like good drama in like
gritty shows like it's a good one anyway
in the show in the second season we
introduced we get introduced to this
woman this again this like skinny kind
of frail unsuspecting white woman who
ends up she ends up running a [__]
drug ring right and she's got these
people that do this and she gets
involved with Zendaya and she's gonna
sell drugs for her anyway
in the show
she talks like this and she's like super
soft-spoken and and it's totally
unsuspecting like she's the [__]
baddest [__] there is but she's this
drug dealer and that speaking pattern
reminds me of that character that and I
don't know if she is how she actually
talks in real life this this actress but
uh where can you find Euphoria you can
find Euphoria on HBO uh or Max now it's
called the app HBO Max nope not it's not
HBO Max anymore it's what it's Max
because Discovery plus and HBO Max they
combine their catalog together because
they're owned by the same company they
[__] and had a baby because it's
Warner Brothers right so it's Discovery
Discovery plus and HBO and they put it
together and now the app is called Max
and their catalog is much bigger ah well
that's good but I guess I don't know if
you're into the pattern of this woman is
very reminiscent of
the character from Wow for you whoa whoa
whoa whoa wait a second Beth on YouTube
says
she herself had an abortion I remember
this in the news you're right not only
that she was using that her story of
abortion as her one of her campaign
um see this is the reason why I think
she's an Android she's not the same
woman anymore
it's weird this is a serious conspiracy
theory okay we should really consider
this because I don't know how you go
through this and then all of a sudden
you switch your political views and
ideologies especially if you ran on
something I'm just saying well Andrew is
Right follow the money because that's
what you gotta do they follow the money
between Android factory that is right
and find it hope brothers and Rupert
Murdoch or someone else I don't know yet
I'll probably do what was that on this
well Elon tweeted that he has
um Rockets maybe he should tweet he has
Androids yeah I don't know it's possible
I mean he's got he's got a lot of trolls
he does have that he owns a lot of
trolls troll Farms speaking of roles
speaking at trolls are alpha cook oh
Matt Walsh is back on bonehead of the
week and he's doing more bone-headed
[__] than he's ever done before he
really really really really is
self-hating himself when he hates the
lgbtq community I think he can't like
you said he can't stop focusing on this
guy is obsessed again the guy the guy is
married
oof but don't even want to know about
that relationship he's married he has
two or three kids now something like
that he just had twins I guess recently
so maybe he has got four kids I don't
know and honestly I don't give a [__] I
feel sorry for that I feel sorry for the
whole [__] family Tony everyone
related that through marriage and
through blood that is now direct
descendant of Matt Walsh I feel sorry
for anyone who has to be within 10 feet
of this [__]
I feel what do you think Matt Walsh she
smells like what do you think he smells
like huh I think Matt Walsh smells like
Bo because he wants to believe that Bo
shows that you're a real man you're a
man
I don't use that [__] [__] let's not
forget he did a ton of his YouTube video
shows in his car in his car right when
he used to talk about marrying underage
girls he would do him in his car
let me tell you something let me tell
you something anyone who does any videos
at all hold on wait I've gotten a few
videos
come on man I had to drop that I had to
give you a [__] all the audience it's
Friday winning it is Friday I gotta give
him [__] like Gustav says soap is woke
yeah it is if you go soap and you go
woke you may go broke I mean just the
thing honestly I wouldn't be surprised
if uh you know actually you know who
could benefit from deodorant a specific
type of deodorant Matt Walsh could
benefit from probably Lumi if I had yeah
well he would not no he would want the
Mando he would definitely want the man
to knock aluminum yeah by the way
speaking of that we're getting closer
and closer to having them as an
affiliate sponsor I'm excited about it I
hope we really I hope we really get this
thing done we're we're back and board
than emails I'm hoping to receive an
email today I'm gonna I'm gonna make a
commercial that's about loomy deodorant
or Mando deodorant maybe it should be
Lumi and be like want to repel those
pesky men and that's the whole
commercial there it's just like in
repelling men oh my God like against the
wall the other commercial I would make
is talking about how Lumi or Mando has
the ability to uh to cleanse your body
of those disgusting right Republican
odors that's true so everyone out there
who is considering buying me don't buy
yet because we may have an affiliate
link we'll get Commission for it I I
think it's an awesome product several
people in the chat already say they use
this stuff and it's [__] fantastic so
don't buy it I should buy it and use the
code I I'm gonna I am I'm gonna I'm
gonna get some and see how my butt
smells I really am speaking of butt
smells um here is uh Matt Walsh he
actually posted this video believe it or
not he they always do they always do I
know he thinks they can Bud Light Target
or some dumb [__] let's let's listen to
what his thought process is here let's
see if it's any different than most of
them that he has H.L Mills says I wish
it were easier to buy only at places
that didn't do the pride crap but even
Walmart has a pride display in June mom
and pop stores are falling by the
wayside it's taking a lot more of an
effort not to support these
organizations but I'm making an effort
um yeah that's that's true and when it
comes to the big box retailers it
probably would be difficult to find one
that doesn't um at least throw a you
know doesn't doesn't do some kind of
pride month The Virtue signaling thing
they all they all uh they all do
something but that's why we have to
again be strategic and you pick your
targets and um maybe one target is
Target but you pick pick something and
you make an example out of that
um
of course he's just talking at his ass
here because his his evidence is is that
Bud Light did you know there's no such
thing as Bud Light anymore they
destroyed Bud Light it's gone what I
bought the very last one at the bar last
night that's the very last Bud Light
that I have in my fridge right now I
should not I should not drink it it's oh
man I'm telling you it's gonna be are we
it's gonna be it's gonna be a rarity
it's gonna be I mean I'm telling you
they're all gone and really Anheuser
bush is going under so is inbev every
single one of the beverage it's their
[__] mine International they took
down an international right a brand
that's crazy because they bought other
beers that that brand makes it's [__]
weird culture baby [__] weird Soldier
you know what else is weird to think
that a bunch of [__] toothless
rednecks bigots are shopping at Target
okay what what are you talking about man
what are you talking about Matt Walsh do
you think you're gonna bring down Target
did you know this about Target what they
will not build a store
where the median income within a certain
amount of miles
is under a hundred thousand dollars did
you know that they will not they will
not and the reason why is because they
want a certain type of people in their
store and guess what kind of people they
don't want in their store people who
listen to Matt Walsh they do not want
those [__] bigoted [__] in
their store they would prefer not to
have their money Target wants to have a
certain type of customer I don't know
have you been in a Target
yeah I've got one not too far from where
I lived oh really so yeah it's actually
it's actually pretty new they just nice
is it nice yeah yeah it's pretty is it
nicer than the Walmart you've been in
well I don't have a Walmart near me have
you been in yeah yeah yeah dude come on
that's what I'm saying so what do you
think about the new Target versus
Walmarts that you buy oh the new Target
is way better is way better it's way
more expensive look I don't even drink
coffee and they've got a Starbucks
inside
it that excites you
all I I hate to disappoint you I
disappoint you but all the targets have
Starbucks do you know why all the
targets have Starbucks well I mean
almost all do you know why they have
Starbucks yeah I know I know they're
trying to attract that customer did you
know did you know did you know I heard I
heard yeah and someone can fact check me
on this but I was told that uh if you go
in to get a coffee
at a Starbucks yeah in a Target you can
get a refill for free
what now what
I was told yeah and someone can if
someone wants to Google this right now
if they want to fact check me but I
remember hearing
from someone that uh that the so in
Target they have Starbucks right and you
can you can get a coffee but you can
also get a refill on a coffee
yeah
why me said no no it's not true okay
hold on you're full of [__] man dude I'm
just saying I'm just saying this is
important conspiracy I said somebody
fact check me I don't know if it's true
I'm making up [__] make it up we really
need that graphic don't we it was it was
it I was told it was true
okay yeah see it's just a regular coffee
that okay that's what I thought it's
just a regular coffee because the the
they're trying to keep you in the store
oh I see see that's why I don't that's
why I don't go to Starbucks I mean I
have been to Starbucks like the last
time with Starbucks because I just drink
my coffee black I don't put anything in
it it's just caught I like coffee
flavored coffee like I want it to be
coffee I don't want it to be anything
else I don't want to be a soda or a
latte or whatever the hell mucho choco
thing I don't know what the hell they
are but I don't want ice in my [__]
coffee I want it hot I want coffee you
know my favorite coffee [__]
McDonald's oh my God that is the best
coffee on the planet some people think
Dunkin Donuts nope you are wrong you're
objectively wrong McDonald's has the
best coffee on the entire planet now
when I say entire planet I mean like in
my bubble right like I haven't been
around the entire planet just drinking
coffee you know what I mean but if I go
somewhere and I want a damn good cup of
coffee I go go to McDonald's my second
choice would be Casey's you know I don't
even know what that is you don't know
Casey's no come on man you grew up in
Illinois surely Casey's is out of Iowa
how do you spell it
Casey's General Store Casey's no what no
[__] are you serious no they're famous
they're famous for people how do you
spell it c-a-s-e-y or K-C it's c-a-s-e-y
Casey like you know he's called Casey
what general store Casey's General Store
Casey's we're famous for pizza that's
literally their slogan okay it's the
best gas station Pizza okay yes this the
sign the Casey General Store sign looks
familiar but I feel like I've only seen
it obviously when I've been like on a
road trip or something that's these
[__] who's Casey come on yeah
who's Casey
um like qt or Circle K now that's down
like Oklahoma Texas qt in Circle K's
down that way Casey's is out of Iowa and
Casey's is in Iowa Northern Missouri
well it's on all in Missouri is it like
a Kum and Go
yes it is like a come and go
how is come and go spelled gave Sanchez
you perv okay with a K so the K get your
mind out of the gutter dude I I knew
where you were going with it yeah
come and go yeah it's just a gas station
you come in and you go you leave
in and out in and out in and out
Big Stuff fan I knew somebody was gonna
bring it up and there's the porn talk
back
zero days talking about porn but I I'm
I'm honestly curious and now I kind of
want to do a little searching after the
show is to know the creation of the name
somebody was like oh yeah come and go
and they're like how did you spell it
and somebody's like with the c and
they're like no no no no with the K and
they're like ah no one will ever figure
us out right no like the idea the idea
that somebody's like come and go that's
a great name and also why would you
spell it C or why would you spell it
k-u-m right like why wouldn't you think
of another name or use the actual come
that you mean what or maybe that is the
[__] that's what I'm asking somebody come
do they mean speaking only only only
because it was requested
yeah
today on the Tony Michaels box oh no no
no turn him on turn him off
okay so I no I I had I had a perfect
transition with the word I had a perfect
transition with come and go speaking of
come and go our bone end of the week
Marjorie Taylor green no that's a rumor
man I don't know if this is a conspiracy
theory or not but uh she may be
she may receive the boner of the week
some people are saying I'm not saying
this the internet is saying this I don't
know if there's any truth to it only a
test could tell only time will tell
summer sang Gabe Sanchez I know Audrey
take the green and I won't say this one
nope
they may be pregnant in it
I heard that he might be pregnant that's
what I've heard on well that is true
I don't I don't actually think it's true
do you think it's true I don't think
it's true no I mean
I mean yesterday that would be quite a
series of events
which whose is it whose is it is it Matt
Gates is it her old husband or is it
goddamn Brian Glenn okay just the idea
of any of those
permutations of people having a baby
is kind of scary it's frightening I feel
bad I feel I just want to say this I
want to say this right now yeah because
children are not born with hate
and they're not born
with uh you know racism and xenophobia
and all these things so I just want to
say to all The Unborn and the newborn
babies
that are in these Republican homes
I'm sorry I feel bad I feel bad for the
the home that they're grown up or
they're they're brought up into
where they can't accept other people and
can't accept themselves for that matter
and I think it's really sad and I feel
sorry
for those for those babies
well I I
hope that um Marjorie Taylor green if
she is pregnant if this um
all right
I hope that I hope that they are allowed
to grow up um for who they are not uh in
their moms I'm hoping I'm hoping this
generation of Republicans that hate
themselves so much that they have to
hate other people I hope that they come
and go out of existence and let the Next
Generation be better than them well
let's see how great she is she and Jamal
Brown uh he he kind of he kind of um
talked to her outside
um in his public space and she was
yelling at him he was kind of raising
his voice and she you know there's
something you know there's a part of
this conference that they that isn't in
this recording
really what
the here I'll the part which one well
let's play this because
all right here we go I had to have so
much security there was not enough I was
swarmed it's all on video everyone can
see this but I will tell you what's on
video is Jamal Bowman shouting at the
top of his lungs oh
my God
promise which I take great offense you
are that is like calling a person of
color the n-word which should never
happen no it's it's not my premises is
equal to that no it's wrong not even
close bow Bowman was down there cursing
at me telling me to get the effort over
there people should curse right outside
the vehicle I was sitting in video
on the capitol steps yesterday yeah he
was the one that approached me even CNN
reported that nope not true shouting
raising his voice he has aggressive uh
physical mannerism he looks black Gabe
Sanchez
didn't do that didn't shove anything I
think there's a lot of concern about
Jamal no there's not and I am concerned
about it I feel threatened
you should you should feel threatened by
him there listen I I wanna I wanna I
wanna make this clear she should feel
threatened by him and here's why is
because I would not want to be Jamal
Bowman's opposition no [__] way would
I want to be Jamal Bowman's opposition
in Congress Jamal Bowman is a very
[__] intelligent person not
only that he has the experience that it
takes to be a serious congressperson and
he really gives a [__] because he's been
in education his entire life he gives a
[__] about education and that's what we
need in Congress people people who are
serious and they give a [__] and she
does it yep go ahead I said he said
yesterday he was like I've got if anyone
knows me I've got
I've got [__] grade school principal
energy right right like I'll bring it at
you and he's like dude if you like
that's I will come at you with love
and enjoy
but when you don't lift a [__] finger
to prevent innocent children in schools
dying and being slaughtered from guns
that you won't stop
anything about doing like the fact they
won't lift the finger like I'm gonna get
very upset and even said he's like the
thing that I did
with Massey was different than the thing
that I did right with Margie Taylor
green yeah right yeah you can see that
it's two different things in those
videos and he never like he laughed he
stated his position he never got closer
she she approached him with her hands
right she tried he was mocking her is
what he was really doing and she got
upset right and she used that conference
that conference as retaliation right
well and she used it as a rage a racist
rebuttal which everyone can see that uh
Margie says something that's very
important um if you guys are gonna call
Congress people which you should uh with
your outrage but you should also call
and with their with your support uh
Margie says I let the message with Jamal
Bowman with his staff at the DC office
saying thank you and keep up the great
work and you should
um you should be making these phone
calls not just not just when you are
upset at some of these people
um especially if you're in their
districts but you should also be
thanking them uh when they do the right
thing even Republicans if a republican
does the right thing you should call and
say I disagree with video on a lot of
things and you should you should change
this this and this but thank you for
doing this because it's the right thing
and and that's what you should be doing
because I'm telling you they're they're
going to listen to you eventually you
got to use your microphone so so call be
polite have that have that grade school
principal energy
um and not only give them outrage but
also also thank them uh it's not
surprising that the petty Yeti was the
bone end of the week it really isn't
that she won I mean she's undefeated
came in you know real she she oh my god
well there's probably 15 Clips I can
play that makes sense I know I know I
know but she really came and went yeah
but didn't she come and go did she come
and go at the time present tense yeah
she did come and go but now she came and
went oh okay uh she just slipped in and
slipped out you know like you didn't
even in and out in and out and uh and it
was great you know I called it yesterday
I said it was a BOGO right the idea that
Jamal Bowman could could mock Margie
Taylor green and Heckle George Santos on
the same Capital step within a few
moments BOGO it's great and Marjorie
Taylor green we're excited that you're
back on bone in the week and of course
you win when you're on Bono the week
let's give him his do
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
of the week thank you very much for
participating everyone stick around
after the song we got a few
announcements and Gabe's got a kick out
of here so stick around right after the
music You Know the music the little
listen
[Music]
foreign
people know the reason why we do the
music is transition from screen to
screen and I don't even do it right what
are you gonna do what are you gonna do
what are you gonna do okay uh Gabe
Sanchez we have a few minutes I want to
uh tell the audience a lot of people
were heard yesterday when we were
talking about YouTube and not being on
YouTube It's Not That We're Not Gonna
stream from YouTube we're definitely
going to show you on YouTube I talked
about this in the first 30 minutes but I
wanted to have a quick conversation for
a minute or two with you about this
We're Not Gonna not stream to YouTube
what we're saying is that YouTube
doesn't give a [__] about our content
and how much time and effort we put into
it so why should we give too much of a
[__] about them why shouldn't we promote
another platform that actually helps us
out and I I I'm not excited about Amazon
exactly but I think it's kind of cool
that Amazon and twitch does this thing
where it's free for an Amazon uh a prime
subscriber to support their favorite
streamer or Creator whatever you want to
call it I I don't consider myself a
streamer exactly maybe a Creator I
really consider myself just a really
loud idiot but the point is this
is that you can support my loud idiocy
and um and that's important and but
we're not going to not stream to YouTube
because we're gonna yeah like that's not
you know I yeah I I mean I would love to
tell YouTube to go [__] themselves and I
think I said that yesterday but but but
I know a lot of people out there watch
our show on television like they use
their TV like I got this TV right here
yeah behind me and they have a YouTube
app on their Smart TV and they're using
the YouTube app to play us yeah probably
right now we're not going anywhere we're
not well unless YouTube Kicks us off
right but that's the point that we're
trying to make is that we want to
continue to do this we want to continue
to make this content and it's super
important that we make a living doing it
how no matter how little or how much
um but we have to like eat and buy Bud
Light so we can you know get gayer and
gayer apparently
um it's how it goes I guess
right that's exactly right so we're not
going anywhere on YouTube
um I was just trying to make the point
that we have twitch over there and
they're doing things over there Facebook
we can monetize I haven't quite done
that yet it doesn't seem as
um as easy for you guys to give us money
or it's free to give us money as it is
on Twitch if you're a prime subscriber
so that's the reason why I like it um
and again if you want to support us
that's awesome it doesn't have to just
be with money you can subscribe right
here on YouTube right now you can hit
the Subscribe button and you can hit the
Bell notification you can also share
this link on all your social media every
single day
every single day I post a link
beforehand you can go grab that link and
you can share it on all your social
media every single day you can download
every single episode that helps us out a
lot too on Apple Spotify Google those
platforms downloading it helps us a
bunch it gives us a ton a ton of metrics
um if you're on Facebook you can watch
it there as well at the Tony Michaels on
Facebook and again if you have a Prime
account you can link it to your Twitch
account all these all this stuff all
these links gave Sanchez you can find at
the Tony michaels.com you can go to the
tonymichaels.com and you can find all
these links how to link your Amazon
Prime account you can find the Twitch
account you can find the Facebook page
you can find Apple Spotify Google all
the podcast directories where it is at
to download you find all that on the
Tony michaels.com we just appreciate we
appreciate all the support rather it's
with money or just being here in the
live audience are replaying this on on
YouTube Facebook twitch wherever you're
watching us wherever you're listening to
us we appreciate you as an audience and
and we hope you have a safe and
wonderful weekend it's been another
great week it's Friday May 19th that's
the two-hour Friday show so I I I see in
the chat that Monday is episode 400. it
is we're gonna celebrate episode 400 on
Monday a Monday 400 that's crazy 400
episodes oh man on Monday same time same
[__] place
Surf's Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em
[Music]
Murphy's mewborn headass Beacon